the
tropics home to millions of species of
animals who clash in Savage battles of
survival but what happens when the
tropics most ruthless turn on each
[Music]
other animals fight tooth and Claw
against their own kind to win
food territory and right to the
bloodline in the wild jungles great
oceans and savanas of the tropics there
are no
rules this is Animal Fight
Night
an Indian
jungle home to the deadly tiger one of
the world's biggest
cats at 450 lb he strikes with 10 times
the force of a heavyweight
boxer he can leap over 30
ft
and when it comes to protecting their
Turf Tiger on tiger clashes bring Savage
battles on an African game reserve this
Amorous male has one thing on his
mind but adult tigers are solitary
living in areas up to 60 square miles
his Hunt For Love Has earned him the
anger of a ferocious
female a tiger can deal an estimated
1,000lb blow powerful muscles in their
front legs and broad shoulders deliver a
force stronger than it takes to hit a
base ball at 90
mph The Tigress Fights Back
fiercely but she could be a future mate
so the lover holds
back allowing The Tigress to land a
painful claw swipe to the
Paw the male cuts his losses and limps
away
[Music]
but the battle isn't over yet the Raging
Skirmish draws another Amorous male into
this Tiger's living room a clash is
inevitable the lover and the young
Bruiser will now duke it out over the
perfect patch and
partner they're matched pound for
pound
which means risking way more than a
scratched paw if he wants to win the
girl he'll have to risk his
life Tiger's specialize in
Ambush and their paws are specially
designed to
help they can retract their claws into
into a protective glove of skin helping
to silence their steps when the tiger
wants to attack the tendons that attach
the claws to the Bone extend unleashing
4in long Sabers a single swipe can take
the face off a
[Music]
human a 10t
leap on his back the Bruiser looks
vulnerable but in this position all his
claws aim at the
lover the lover can't get in close
enough he Jabs with his 4in
claws and Deals a bloody blow
but the tigers are
tiring heavy bones and dense muscle mass
they're built for short bursts of
aggression the young Bruiser is blooded
and looks beat the lover thinks he's
nail
it but the Bruiser still
standing
he's got the advantage of Youth on his
side what the Bruiser lacks an
experience he makes up for with combat
stamina overcoming Home
Advantage A Sucker Punch turns the fight
on its
head he goes straight for the
jugular
his 3-in canines are the longest of any
cat gaps between the canines and back
teeth allow him to sink his teeth deep
into
prey nerve endings in his teeth are so
sensitive that he can feel exactly where
to bite to sever the spinal
cord delivering up to 1,000 lb of
pressure per square in
unlike a human jaw tiger Jaws can only
move up and down not side to
side so no amount of twisting by the
prey slackens the
grip male tigers can kill one another
but this time the Bruiser just teaches
an old cat a lesson the lover is
bloodied but still
alive the Bruiser takes his territory
and his pick of the
females for his rudeness the older tiger
accepts his heavy
punishment big cats aren't the only
supersized Fighters prowling the
tropical back
[Music]
country
the same weight as 25 grown men the
Rhino is the second largest land
dwelling mammal on
earth and it has a secret
weapon its sense of
smell its odor detection system is
bigger than the rest of its brain put
together a rhino can detect the age and
sex of another Rhino from Up to a mile
away and when they don't like what they
smell it's fight
[Music]
time the old bull is picking up the
scent of a young
male this Challenger wants to boot him
out and take over his
Turf the old bull weighs up the risks
the young Challenger is smaller than him
but makes up for it with youthful
agility without territory the old bull
may never made
again he hurdles at 30 m hour toward his
enemy the same Force as a pickup
truck the young Challenger braces for
impact dropping his head to protect his
neck from a
skewering the old Bull's armed with a 2T
Long
Horn weighing 6 lb it's made of the
protein
keratin and because it contains no
nerves it can't feel pain only inflicted
mounted on his 800 pound head the force
behind a single uppercut can be
fatal a crafty hook and he has him where
he wants
him one frust could Gore the young
Challenger's
underbon where the skin is half as thick
as on his armed
back
but instead he tosses him more than a
foot off the ground with neck muscles so
strong he can sling the weight of a
family car into the air a second leg
lock drives the message
home take on this old timer at your
peril but the old bull lets him off the
hook this
time he's taught the Young challeng a
golden rule of
Engagement pick on someone your own
size next up a surprising contender in
animal fight
night this penguin might look cute and
cuddly but when it comes to fighting
over females there's nothing cute about
a bloody beat to the
face
this neotropical South American
Peninsula is the goto vacation
destination for the melanic
penguin this devoted husband has spent
all day Gathering food for his
wife
every September 200,000 Penguins flock
here to fix up their nests and
breed life here is
good but this husband has come home to
find his wife with another
penguin he flips out his strategy is
simple batter the home wrecker until he
flees most birds have hollow bones in
their wings to make them lighter for
flight but Penguins don't fly their
flippers contain solid bone they use
them like baseball bats to Club each
other delivering up to eight blows a
second thick blubber helps protect vital
organs from the
[Music]
puming
State the love Rivals call to the female
to let her decide the
[Music]
Victor she chooses the home
wrecker the husband stands to lose the
mother of his
children he follows them home this fight
isn't over
yet with the home wrecker hiding in the
burrow the only way to get to him is
with a beak
attack Penguins usually use their beaks
to gouge their
Burrows now they are gouging out
eyes
[Music]
the husband escalates the fight he
stands to lose more than his partner an
injured penguin is a prime target for
Hungry Birds of
Prey he makes one last plea to the
female but she's got no time for losers
[Music]
defeated and humiliated he's left out in
the
[Music]
cold he'll lick his wounds and move
on in a colony of nearly a quar of a
million there are plenty more fish in
the
[Music]
sea
being a fish in the sea comes with its
own set of
problems in Shallow Waters this shark is
used to taking his pick when it comes to
lunch but an octopus shows who boss 6ot
long arms and over 2,000 suckers lock
the sharp down slowly strangling it to
death but when octopuses fight each
other arms don't cut it they fight dirty
and face being eaten by their own
kind the baly Waters of
Myanmar home to this armed
assassin who's hot in pursuit of another
octopus
he caught red-handed snooping in his
food
stash as the Assassin closes in the
snooper takes
off breaking out some of the animal
Kingdom's smartest secret
weapons a squirt of ink creates a smoke
screen he flees the
scene when an octopus needs to move fast
it uses its own inbuilt jet
engine a siphon in the mantle sucks
water in and spits it out at 27
mph the same swimming speed as a
barracuda propelling it head first
through the water like a
bullet but the Assassin still has him in
his sights
the snooper tries a different
trick
camouflage but hiding doesn't cut
it the Assassin prepares to strike with
the most deadly weapon of all a venomous
bite from a hidden
[Music]
beak
this angry octopus won't give
up if the snooper doesn't step up or get
away he could become
lunch there's one part of these
invertebrates that isn't soft and
slippery each octopus has a mouth at the
center of its body
it's like a parrot's beak and every bit
is sharp inside the beak is a tongue
with a strip of teeth glands release
paralyzing
Venom the Assassin closes
in the snooper fights
back
assassin turns
capable the snooper becomes
[Applause]
Sushi high above the oceans in the
mountainous rainfall forests of
[Music]
Kenya a Jackson's chameleon makes light
work of
lunch this High Roller has food a canopy
condo and all the girls he can get his
claws
[Music]
on his neighbor is Green With Envy
he wants the roller patch and the
girls it's time for a treetop
joust in the tall rainforest trees the
stakes are high the loser is for the
long
drop these are their not so secret
weapons three bone horns with a keratin
coating
evolve solely for the purpose of
dueling the Challenger sets his sights
on the High
Roller he can rotate each eye
180° in different directions without
moving his
head so one eye always remains trained
on the
enemy
the High Roller hiss is a warning to
stand
down but the Challenger needs to risk it
all to improve his breeding
[Music]
rights game
on the aim of the game is to topple your
opponent from the branch the winner
keeps the
territory the first tactic Lance each
other with their custombuilt
weapons natural selection has given the
High Roller longer
horns a breakage is intensely painful
and leaves the owner
unarmed he tries to pierce the four
layers of skin on his opponent's
head these guys have a head for
Heights it's like wrestling on an iron
girder on top of a 20 story
highrise their pins are like feet act as
clamps a leg grab forces the Challenger
off the
branch their tails are as long as their
bodies and act as safety
harnesses
the High Roller channels all the power
in his neck
muscles into a powerful head
flick game
over the fall is physical and
hierarchical if he wants to breed he'll
have to duel with someone else
because here the High Roller is still
top of the
tree Australia is the place our next
Contender calls
home meet the
kangaroo animal fight nights very own
mixed martial artists who go
head-to-head for total Ultimate
[Music]
Fighting 25 ft in a single
lead Brak neck speeds of over 35
mph as fast as a
wol solid muscle makes up 80% of its
body mass making the male kangaroo Built
For
Fighting it's easy to see why a group of
kangaroos is called a
mob and when they
Clash they become Nature's ultimate
kickboxing
Champions this monster has been in
charge for 2 years years twice as long
as
usual he's still armed and
dangerous within the mob ranks are
strict the only way to the top is to
fight your way
up now this Deputy is tired of playing
second fiddle but he has to be sure he
can
win the mobster has exclusive rights to
the females
with those kinds of privileges at stake
fights often get ugly and
deadly the mobster must crush this
[Music]
Rebellion the deputy takes some
shots but comes
back they interlock claws to hold each
other off that was just the start it's
time to pull out the big
guns a kangaroo's spine runs all the way
to the end of its tail over 3 ft long it
has up to 25 vertebra support supported
by
ligaments their tails can support their
entire body weight balancing on their
tails their legs go into trigger mode
their large muscles contract and release
a massive burst of energy delivering a
mega
kick their kicks are so loud they can be
heard nearly 500 ft
away
the force pushed through double claws on
their fused second and third toes could
disembowel so kangaroos have evolved
extra thick skin on their
stomachs the kicking's not cutting it
the mobster tries something new the neck
grab claws nearly 2 in long are sharp
enough to puncture eyes
so they throw their heads back for
protection exposing their necks to being
ripped
open a powerful floor
slam and the deputy knows he's fighting
a losing
battle he waves the white
flag with a grunt satisfied the mobster
leaves him to wallow in his
defeat and returns to his mob to remind
them whose boss
1700 M Northwest in the steamy mangrove
swamps of
Indonesia lurks the world's second
largest lizard the water
[Music]
monitor armed with 54 serrated teeth
there's no creature this extreme
carnivore won't eat
it's even been known to dig up and
devour human
corpses monitors are solitary creatures
who really don't get
along but breeding time brings them to
the same watering hole and such Close
Quarters Means
War this male monitor is top do dog he
gets the best of everything the most
food and his choice of
females this Challenger is willing to
risk injury and even death for a slice
of the
action monitors fight prey on four legs
monitor on monitor upright is preferred
it's a full-on Sumo grapple there their
legs are so strong they can outrun an
Olympic
sprinter now they harness that power
trying to slam each other into the
riverbed strong clawed feet mean they
can hang from a tree by a single
toe round one to Top Dog but it's not
over
yet their tails are 1 and 1/2 times the
length of their bodies and pack full of
muscle the Challenger uses his as a
third leg anchoring him to the riverbed
but it's not
enough
[Music]
Smackdown round three and the Challenger
knows he's
lost the top dog retains his title for
another
day you don't need all the moves to win
in animal fight
night sometimes a single strike is
enough to take the
title
in the Vietnamese jungle this 4-year-old
Burmese python is out for
lunch and he's just spotted his favorite
bite a nice juicy
rat the hungry Diner constricts his 16
ft long body around
it pythons can go months without eating
but when they do they really pig out
they can eat their own body weight in
one sitting that's like a grown man
eating a 200 lb
cheeseburger once he's gulped down his
fast food he'll slope off to a Sunny
Spot and spend several days digesting
it but not so fast a rat thief's Fort
tongue sniffs him
out the tongue two prongs pick up scent
from different
directions giving him stereo
[Music]
smell and he wants a piece of the
pie an opportunist it's easier to steal
than catch something
himself the diner quickly stashes away
his
rat if the thief wants the rat he'll
have to think
big he goes for the
diner with 350 bones in his spine 10
times that of a human he Loops his body
around the diner
he contracts his muscles to tighten the
coil and squeezes so tight his victim
can't breathe each time the victim
breathes out the python tightens the
coil death by
Suffocation the python can feel its
victim's heartbeat stop once it does
he relaxes the
coil a full-grown Burmese could easily
strangle an adult human to
death the rat Thief has committed a
crime now he must dispose of the
evidence he can dislocate his own jaw
and get his mouth around something five
times bigger than his own
head
his backward-facing teeth act as
ratchets driving his victim further down
into his
belly as the rat Thief swallows the
diner he begins to redesign his own body
to Aid digestion
over the next few days his metabolism
will increase
Sevenfold his heart and intestine will
expand by up to
150% leaving not a shred of
evidence the tropical Mountain forests
of Western India stomping ground of the
traven cor tortoise it may not be fast
but it's nothing less than
Furious this Trooper has been having an
off-duty snooze to keep
cool but something's got him hot and
bothered there's been a Breakin and
someone's making himself right at home
he might only be 13 in long but this
Invader wants to wage
war he plans to run the trooper out of
town Annex his land and take all his
women the trooper needs to mobilize fast
or he'll be homeless and
Loveless he storms
[Music]
over
but is met with a series of sharp
nips too many bites will damage the
trooper's only mode of
transportation leaving him unable to
find
food he takes cover under his hard
hat rallies
himself and hits back with his biggest
weapon
yet these are nature's Mini miniature
battering rams and given they live
around 30 years they get a lot of
practice it might look like these
Warriors are in slow mod but they are
operating at maximum tortoise
Speed The Trooper reels his front legs
back to inject as much force as possible
into his body
blows
he tries to flip the Invader if he can
capsize him he could be stuck on his
back and starve to
death but the Invader is no stranger to
some heavy shelling he bites back even
harder the trooper beats a hasty retreat
he'll have to set up cam somewhere
else there's more than one pint-sized
prize fighter in the tropics the
rainforests of Thailand playground of
the quirkiest contender in the animal
fight night
Fray the styed
[Music]
fly
this little fella is newly
hatched but before he Ventures out into
the world there's one last thing he
needs to
do he sucks in air to form
bubbles the bubbles travel up through
his head inflating his eye
stalks the whole process takes only 15
minutes
transformation complete he's no longer
just a
fly he's
Superfly and it's time for a fly
[Music]
fight styed flies are a social Bunch the
males and females hang out together
every
night and all the chicks go weak at the
knees for a guy with a substantial stalk
it's a sign of
virility the new kids been blessed by
Nature his stalk is so long it's the
same length as his
body he heads out to test drive his new
stock
but someone's eyeballing
him the styed fly has an excellent field
of vision their eyes are like balls on
stalks and covered in around
2,500 tiny
lenses so they can see behind their
heads and their Vision at the front
overlaps by up to
70% perfect for spotting a peripheral
threat
this aggressive fly is also well
endowed there's only room for one big
stalk in this
town the new kid lifts his front legs to
demonstrate the size of his
stock he measures
up he he's won the right to challenge
the big
[Music]
shot they go stalk to stalk trying to
butt each other off the
branch if the new kid can OU the big
shot he'll have rights to all females
who pass
by budding star box isn't
working the new kid changes
up he starts throwing
punches each of their six feet has two
pads that release a type of glue
anchoring their back legs to the branch
so they can rear up and
Spar these fights can can last over a
minute a fair stretch in a fly's 8 we
lifetime it all comes down to stamina
this new kid has youth on his
side the big shot can't keep
up he runs off his pride dented and his
chances with the ladies
ruined the new kid rubs his hands
together with
Glee
a mobile city of 1 and a/2 million
wilderbeast they live Bumper to
Bumper the only other mammals to live
this densely are humans on the Move
these Wanderers of the African
wilderness get along
fun but when they stop to breed friends
become
foes able to run at 40
mph and with lethally sharp
horns when these Bulls go head-to-head
in a bid to extend their
bloodline only the toughest referees can
break up the
fight this mature male is guarding a
patch of land filled with his female
mates he marks his territory with scent
glands but he's got
competition a cocky young Bachelor bull
without a bachelor
pad he wants to kick the older male out
of town
and inherit his
females the young Bachelor
strikes they fight on their
knees each Beast has horns that curve up
90° dead L hooks nearly 3 ft
long an uppercut to the jugular would
cause fatal blood
loss known as twist fighting they bow
and turn their heads to protect their
necks from a
stabbing the young Bachelor beats the
old Bull in size he uses his powerful
neck muscles to lob him into the
air
the youngster tries a new
tactic a half
Nelson his horn is in a precarious
position one jab could pierce the old
Bull's
underbelly it's too close to the vital
organs the youngster shown how far he's
prepared to
go
the risks are too
great The Old bull makes a run for it
leaving his herum
behind the triumphant young Bachelor has
earned his right to the top spot
[Music]
a